now making predictions is of course a
mug's game so let's give it a go George
is now three of Sky's finest brains this
clarifies Liz Lerman economics editor at
Conway and diplomatic editor Dominic
Waghorn thank you very much for coming
in okay morning
pretty much yeah I'm just going to try
and pin you all down no I'm joking
and I just thought that after it's such
an extraordinary year we Snelling in New
Year's in 2019 it's good time to kind of
kick back and try and take stock have a
look back at 2018 and thread forward to
what we think might happen in what I
think is gonna be one of the most
unpredictable years of journalism that I
can remember so like I thought I'd start
off by chatting about any standout
moments for you guys from 2018 Domenic
on the sort of foreign affairs brief
there's only thing that really sort
stood out to you well there's a whole
sort of year of crazy to pick from and
I'm tempted to go with Trump's meeting
with Kim jong-un the in Singapore
because it was kind of everything you
expect from Donald Trump and and more it
was sort of you know it was a triumph of
spectacle over substance it was a
classic case of Trump because I'm
confessing a crisis with his little man
a little Rocket Man fire and fury
rhetoric that terrified us all for much
of the year and then kind of diffusing
that crisis but actually emerging with
nothing of real substance in what he
ended up deciding with a little rocket
man up there but I think it doesn't beat
what happened later in Helsinki when
Trump meant Trump meant Putin and we
still don't know what they talked about
but afterwards he stood that's the
Russian leader and astounded the world
by saying that he prefer to take the
Russian leaders words word about whether
Russia compact America's elections over
the word of his own spy agencies and I
think that goes to the heart of the kind
of the riddle at the heart of the Trump
presidency which we still don't have an
answer for which is what what has he got
on him
and what does that mean for America's
national interest and hopefully we'll
get an answer to that this year fingers
crossed
well it's been an extraordinary year in
global politics it has been domestic
politics that's what has lit fight so
what do you think was the your kind of a
standout moment they're definitely too
many but if I pick one it will be
decisive moment a moment of indecision
which was the decision to delay
the vote which one you because it
contains everything in it you build up
to that moment historic moment as we
were repeatedly told for weeks and
months leading up to it your entire sort
of cabinet summits about how to prepare
for it to then delay it it's quite
something and it sort of got lost there
were so many things that happen last
year they got slightly lost in the sort
of general flow of extraordinary
political no none of this and all this
is normal particularly when you then see
the consequence of that is that the vote
was delayed by more than a month at
least and now there are various mp's
starting to predict that the vote won't
happen on the 15th or 16th either and
yet at the very same time you have the
political track of this whole brexit
thing but you also have the reality
track and the reality track was at that
moment a government department the
parent transport was drafting a contract
for ferries in Ramsgate it's all for
ferry service and Ramsgate using the
words this is a moment of extreme
urgency I mean it's there in black and
white in the car in the contract award
notice that slips out over Christmas so
you have on the one hand the government
asserting for legal purposes were in a
moment of extreme urgency as regards
brexit but on the other hand delay in
this vote by over a month and
potentially for longer what about the
economics of it already because actually
in a way it has been the politics you
know whether it's Trump or indeed it
breaks it that has been driving the
economic story for quite some time we've
been looking at the markets and seeing
the reaction but the interesting thing
and the interesting kind of moments were
period for me was the final month of the
year normally people investors talk
about a kind of Santo rally don't they
Marc is gonna go up as people start to
you know get ready for Christmas if I
was the complete opposite markets on in
the US to some extent over here just
completely plummeted we had the worst
December that we've seen since 1930 and
why is that happening it's because
economics is starting to come back to
bite the politics you know you've got
the Federal Reserve raising interest
rates that's causing this kind of knock
on chain of consequences around the
world in the US but elsewhere as well
Argentina Turkey we saw crises there
over the course of this year that's big
stuff of interest rates are starting to
be a big story now people are worried
about China as well what's your
predictions then so what
can happen next year well I think I mean
I'm one of them and it kind of comes
along from that and I should say you
know we're all marks if we make
predictions and you know have us back in
a year's time to die I suspect probably
it's been a long time since we've had a
recession in a g7 country I think we
might well guess another one over the
course of the next year we might we'll
hear about it in the next three months
even Germany looks like it may well be
kind of close to that and I think it's
but might well be more than one g7
country so the top countries a nice
optimistic prediction well yeah I mean I
haven't got much more to cheer people up
with and I think of this some of your
people do sort of you know observers get
together and indulge in navel-gazing and
say we don't really know how it's going
to work out but let's hope it's a good
year I think probably geopolitically
we're not hoping for the best of years
we're hoping the least bad of years
given what we're facing in America not
least and I think you know you're
looking at a president who is
temperamentally unsuitable to be in the
job and it's been a roller coaster ride
so far but he has had stabilizers on him
in the form of these former generals
mattis Kelly McMaster he's now trying to
by not so much yes-men but people who do
his bidding that they're intelligent
people Pompeo Bolton and others but they
they don't descent and what what's
really point to say is every presidency
so far if you think about Obama and the
the financial meltdown george w bush and
9/11 his father with the invasion of
kuwait every president does face a major
crisis a massive global crisis that they
have to deal with and we've not had one
with trump there so far interesting to
see how around we've we've been lucky so
when exactly but when it does as it
surely will at some point how are you
going to cope without those kind of
restraints on well it feels like the
prime ministers in the crisis right now
what's your political prediction for
2019 okay so I could sort of equivocate
and say well I could go this work of the
other way but if you I would say we
unlike last year which was a bit of an
oddity in terms of what we've seen over
the past four years I think at some
point this year we will be going back to
some sort of national
poll of some description the ballot
boxes will be reused and the reason I
say that is you just have this
fundamental impasse don't you which is
that that I believe that there is a
majority in parliament that just does
not want to see a No Deal brexit but
it's no doubt that it's the default
option so some how can that can that's
majority in parliament Express that will
particularly in the case when was we saw
in the internal Conservative Party
membership polling where you have
conservative members seventy percent of
whom want to know deal or would accept a
No Deal I think it's generally a good
idea
which if you don't think Parliament
would it's not - yeah I don't well I
haven't thought it actually frankly so
if you haven't thought it since after
the general election the numbers are
fairly obvious really now whether they
have the parliamentary method to stop it
is another question whether or not
whether by mistake yes yes so I'm not
ruling out No Deal but I'm saying that
the will is there from what I calculate
in Parliament to stop the train track
heading towards No Deal we're out of
time yeah that was fastly so I want to
call you back to find out if it's true
thank you very much